this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday the 12th
of september the joint is brought to you
by
draftkings listen
if you missed out on the first weekend
of the nfl you [__] up because the
nfl's opening week was action-packed and
it's just getting started tonight we got
denver versus seattle get ready for week
two of the big game with draftkings
sportsbook the official sports betting
partner the nfl this week tonight new
customers can bet five dollars on any
football game and get 203 bets now if
you want more action i guess i'll tell
you what i got for you
you can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion
it's simple better than the nfl team to
win if your team leaves by 10 at any
point during the game you get paid
instantly even if your team loses
download the draftking sports pickup app
right now
use promo code joey to get 200 free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet on any football game start tonight
with denver
playing seattle
that's co joey only at draftking
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply
see show notes for details draftkings
download it right now
and go win some [__] money
that's it [__] let's get this
party started it's monday
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joint
my
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here for another fun-filled
week
of the [__] joint was a great
weekend a great week great ufc before we
get anything started
i want to you know america 20 [__]
one years
we don't know what the [__] happened we
were all waking up planes were flying
around people were yelling nobody knew
what the [__] happened
and uh here we are today it was funny
because i went to the gym yesterday
morning just to ride the bike and
stretch on sunday
and the tv was on when i walked in they
said no music today because on 9 11 and
i was like [__] i forgot all about 911.
you know you remember the date but you
forget it's 9 11 today
and uh i was riding the bike and the tv
was on and they were doing a a memorial
from nine from the 911 spot like
the world trade center i guess
and it was just like two people at a
time reading out all the names of the
people and
you know because when you hear whatever
1400 people whatever that's it's a
number
but when i was on the bike and i was
seeing the names coming up and
and where they were from
[Music]
and
you know their ages
that was a [__] horrible horrible
horrible
[__] day like these guys would have
been 40 today like i read a ton of kids
you know 26
30 and yeah there was a lot of a lot of
seniors like 52
51 there were guys from colt's neck guys
from my area that commute to new york
and it just [__] dawned on me for a
second like what the [__] happened that
day and
you know i'm a new yorker at [__]
heart i mean all i know is this area as
a kid so on 9 11 it did [__] with me a
little bit you know like when i woke up
in new york and
i called my friends and i called
whatever family i had and it was uh
it was just a shitty day you know and
but i got a lesson out of this that's
real important and that's what i've been
telling you [__] for years
yes it was 21 years ago and it was a sad
day in [__] america but guess what
america bounced back like a [__]
it happened 21 years ago that's it it's
over we remember it
we remember the people like there's a
kid from my high school that went in
there to save somebody he was a cop and
he never came back out chris amoroso
they have a benefit from every year this
year was on a saturday night
and uh
it's just weird like when you look at it
now you know and you see what the [__]
we're made of as americans
yeah that was a bad day for us and we
all have [__] bad days in life and a
micro uh sense you know but guess what
man it gets better and you keep moving i
mean there was a bunch of people there
going you know grandma never met you
but uh
you know i think about you every day and
[__] that that was just a hard
day in america yes it was but guess what
we [__] got up
we moved forward
we went over there and a little bunch of
[__] uh you know
people on fire whatever the [__] we did
how we did it when we did it it doesn't
concern us in a way it's something way
bigger than us that any of us could ever
comprehend
but
like that's what i got out of it this
morning we're [__] americans man
we do whatever the [__] we want this is
[__] america you understand me and
that's what's wrong with people today
they're slipping they're forgetting that
we're [__] america
okay and while you're worried about
pronouns and [__] taking medication
and doing all this [__] america's
[__] america [__] don't ever
[__] forget that i love living here
and i love being a part of this and i
love [__] knowing
that as a [__] american you could
have a [__] bad day like i did when i
found my [__] mother and guess what
have another bad day of [__] going to
jail for something you did nobody
[__] put you in there because you
were just at home whistling dixie don't
get me wrong but at the same [__]
time as an american we bounce back
it's our toughness this is what our
lives are about not about worrying about
pronouns or [__] you know
it's not
it's it's gone away we're americans we
fall and we get the [__] up
immediately
we don't sit there and wait for a
[__] uh
jesus to come and wake you and tap you
on the [__] shoulder this is america
so yes it was 9 11 yesterday and yes it
happened 21 [__] years ago and it was
a horrible [__] day but guess what as
americans
we bounced back and we're slinging dick
with three [__] hands and guess what
that'll never happen again that'll never
happen again we're [__] prepared
so all you [__] that want to be
woke and are worried about all the
[__] wrong things in this life that's
going on right now worry about [__]
us we're [__] americans
and that's it and we [__] up and we get
up and we plow through it and if we [__]
up again we get up again and we plow
[__] through it that's what this
means
you know and it's like i said sad a
plain hit
all this [__] is bad but guess what us
getting up
is the most important thing and we got
up and this is a lesson for [__]
everybody this is a lesson for everybody
those people that walked in that day
they didn't know they were gonna [__]
get hit in the head with a [__]
missile nobody [__] knew
so it just baffles me that
we're worried about all these [__]
things in today's world i mean all these
things that don't aren't even gonna
[__] matter in 20 [__] years
we're gonna we're gonna look at this as
a joke remember when everybody tried to
be woke oh my god get the [__] out of
here
remember when we were [__] americans
that's what i want you [__] to
remember that we're [__] americans
[__] you [__] [__]
[__] your weakling [__] your [__] uh
your allergy to peanut we're [__]
americans man
and we're dwelling too much on this [__]
what we're weak on but we
we work from strength i work from
[__] strength i try to do my hardest
to work from [__] strength except for
dying my [__] hair you know what i'm
saying you gotta work from weakness but
anyway that's what's going on in my
world on a beautiful [__] monday
morning the day after 9 11. that's what
the message i [__] got you know we're
americans man sticks and stones or break
our bones but words will never what the
[__] is going on today
everybody's sensitive everybody's
worried about the [__] wrong things
and i'm done with this [__]
conversation because i get [__]
irritated
it's a beautiful [__] day to be alive
it's a beautiful monday
i had to dye my hair we're making
progress guys i haven't heard from the
[__]
play but i did hear from the movie that
i was very
uh excited about
first they hit me back and we go joey
do us a favor
you taped against a white wall i i
forgot like i taped against a white wall
with a black suit on
and i had a white face and white [__]
hair so i blended right into the white
so they called on uh i had to put the
audition on tape
for tuesday i called they called back
wednesday they're like joey we need a
big favor
don't get insulted can you dye your hair
and i'm like what out of all the [__]
requests
like can you dye your hair your white
hair just mixed into your skin color and
it mixed into the wall you look like a
[__] locust do you mind doing it
i'm like okay i'll do it it's a lot of
[__] verbage so i sat down i got the
teleprompter set up again
and i had to read with my [__] wife
okay
i didn't look at the audition because i
thought my wife was looking at me
when i asked her how was the audition
she goes it was great you and i
i knew the words i knew the you know
but
after she sent the [__] thing i saw
that the audition was on my phone and i
looked at it and i'm like
i didn't look at the camera the computer
was down here so i kept reading and
looking up at the camera and i'm like
what the [__] thank god they called on
friday and said joey
we liked your read but only one thing
can you do it again and stand up
because i was sitting down for the read
because it's me at a table with two
other gangsters talking [__]
so i said fine so they gave me till
friday
to get my [__] together i've been
studying them every day this [__]
weekend
i sat down 30 minutes i ran over them
and my wife came home we sat down went
over for a half hour they told me they
don't want the tape by [__] friday
i'm gonna work this [__]
audition from every angle i can
and i'm gonna get this [__] role i
just feel that good about it i got
another audition too where i play like a
brother and a [__] brother
marco and marcus i got to play too
[__] i can't deal with that [__] i
gotta do concept changes and wardrobe
changes
that [__] ain't for me i can't and plus
it coincides so i got a pilot i'm
shooting october 4th and then i got this
[__] movie hopefully with the grace
of god and this week we start the
residency
saturday night i know the tickets are
sold out and people are pissed and
whatever listen i put them on sale you
know uh
i don't know
it's the lucky draw i'm gonna add some
new shows nothing in jersey but i'm
gonna have some new shows in new york
try to do a long island show one of
these weekends maybe on a thursday night
up at the [__] i talked to linda rowe
i owe her a call you know i'm gonna
spread it out a little bit i've been in
jersey too much but the jersey residency
is over with guys thank god i had a
great time i appreciate everybody who
came to the shows uncle vinnie's did a
[__] great job natalie cuomo i mean
it was just a great little [__]
situation but it's time
to move up into the [__] theater it's
time for uncle joey
on broadway i had a great time in point
pleasant but it's time to go smoke some
dope with some [__] savages over
there in [__] new york city
yeah it was a great weekend man uh the
ufc was crazy you know listen guys
i don't discuss the ufc on here as much
as a lot of people would like me to do
because
there's 200 podcasts that do it they
already discuss a lot of ufc you know
and
i watch like this there's weeks i forget
that there's a fight on people hit me up
on patreon joey did you watch the phone
like [__] i didn't even know that like i
didn't watch serial gains against
tuivasa i don't watch a lot of fights
but this one i wanted to watch i wanted
to see
what had happened i mean friday was
[__] up there was a fight i guess on
thursday
at the press conference
no no it was uh two teams were yelling
in the back kevin holland's team and
cosmet's team and [__] nate diaz
started throwing bottles i i don't know
i wasn't there
but they canceled it so it looked like
it was gonna be great fireworks so
i watched the fights uh i watched like
uh i watched the girl i watched
the first fight yeah i watched all of
the fight i didn't watch any prelims or
anything i had two softball games on
saturday i had one softball game on
sunday
[__] pool party on saturday you know
so i got i came home just in time to
watch the [__] card and it was great
you know man you watched these guys when
i started watching the ufc i am not like
i didn't watch ufc two or three i didn't
even know what the [__] was going on
i didn't jump on board trying this
silver came on to the league and it's
really weird that the people that i
started watching
over the years are now getting older you
know nick diaz nate diaz uh
they're gone gsp the guys i started you
know
john fitch who's on [__] uh twitter
doing fight programs she's [__] great
you know all these guys were the guys i
came into the ufc with and now a lot of
these fighters i have no idea who the
[__] they are you know
the fight game moves so fast but i want
to watch nate against uh
tony ferguson i know both of them
they're very nice [__] guys
great fighters you know the cosmonaut
fight i don't know
he picked that guy up and threw him
around
by his neck like a [__] chicken that
dude is out of his [__] mind
that cosmic listen guys i've met a lot
of people
you know you know i i got my own
problems i met a lot of crazy people but
that cosmonaut that dude is crazy every
time he goes whoo i'm like oh my god
because he always comes out yelling i'm
a hit man this i'm going to murder this
guy and also at the end he goes
and i'm like oh jesus christ this guy is
hearing voices and [__] somebody's gonna
die in that [__] octagon but it was
great i bet nick diaz i didn't you know
listen those ufc fights
if you're looking to bet and win money
on them there's no money on them like i
if you bet
check kazmoth to win last night you won
nine dollars
you put up like 25
to win nine dollars you know what i'm
saying i like fights where you you put
up 25 you win 60 at least double your
[__] money to watch the fight for
your time but
i bet diaz small and i bet diaz to win
by decision
which i lost that [__] uh thing but
it was still a great fight
it was great to see him and you know
here's the thing about nate diaz
here's the thing about a lot of people
you know
perception is
[__] huge sometimes
and
the perception
that we have of certain people like
myself you look at nate diaz
you could tell he smokes dope you can
tell he's punched drunk a little bit
he's been punching the head a couple
times
but let me tell you something about nate
diaz he's a [__] intelligent guy
those five to be a fighter you have to
be
listen let's quote this to be a fighter
and to last 20 years in the fight game
there has to be some intelligence that
has to be some composure
you know he ended his contract at the
ufc 20 fights whatever all these guys
you know
you have to respect that but when you
look at a guy like nate diaz or some of
these other fighters you always bring
like your own judgment in like maybe
he's a fighter maybe he's not that sharp
these guys you know somebody gave nate
diaz that million dollars when he fought
when he beat uh
mcgregor the first time
and yeah he must have bought a pound of
pot and some sneakers and [__] but he
took his money and he invested it
correctly then he got another million
and god knows
how many millions he got over the
[__] years and he invested them
and you know he wants to do a promotion
now he wants to he wants to do other
things that's what he said
he wants to master other things and
that's called evolution guys
you know
there's nothing worse than
seeing a guy and he's like whoa i'm
gonna go up to all the leagues and make
money and kick the [__] out everybody
nate's not talking about that
he's evolving he's evolving
how many guys do you see that truly
really evolve
they go through the ufc and then they
go you know they get cut and they go to
the pfl or something
or uh bellator they have a couple
different things but
at the end of the day you know
you're 40 with no work
and
yeah you could teach martial arts you
could open up a school you could train
other guys and stuff like that you know
it's
it's amazing when you pick something and
it opens up other doors for you for the
future
as right here
i got into stand-up i
was so insecure i didn't think i could
ever do anything
but i thought i had a grip with stand up
i fit all you know like when you uh
you know look at job qualifications like
high school diploma a valid new jersey
driver's license you know
prerequisites well prerequisites for
comedy are like [__] drinking
doing drugs and you know so they fit who
i was at the time
as i got older you know i still did the
drugs and i still enjoyed doing stand-up
but then i met someone and then
the
not the odds change but
it's not that the odds ever change it's
that the stakes change
the stakes change you're looking for
different things now you're not looking
for a big [__] house anymore it's
like a 40 year old divorced woman she's
not looking for i want a guy that looks
like richard gere that comes up with a
horse no that ship sailed you got
cheated on he [__] your sister listen
right now you just want a guy that's got
teeth a job and insurance and that's
what they you know you just you adjust
your [__] outlook you know
one of the biggest fears i ever had with
anything in life was
having a job and
having a great job or a great career
like comedy or boxing or something that
you work on commission a musician
something like that that you work on
commission you know
and you do your 20 years old or
something then one day you decide you
know what this is not what i want to do
anymore i still enjoy playing the guitar
but i think i want to broaden my
horizons with with uh producing and
maybe
teaching the guitar and maybe managing a
band you know that's the next evolution
of guys when i got to the comedy store
one of the
scariest things
for me like
and guys
i never really had a lot of fears of the
future because i never thought i was
going to make it
i never thought i was going to make it
past 37. i never thought
and then when i hit 40 i'm like
holy [__] i hit 40. what's gonna happen
now so
i never really prepared
for the future but it was always on on
the back burner it was on the back it
was one of those things that comes up
every once in a while in your life and
you go [__] it i don't want to think
about that right now it'll all work out
but it's not going to work out and then
i hit my 40s and
and i remember when i was
44 45 or whatever i got married and
everything [__] changed like
everything changed immediately when i
got mad i don't know what happened to me
i still wanted to do stand-up i still
wanted to act i still want to do a lot
of things but i wanted something to
change you know so i said maybe i'll
sell some cars and the podcasting thing
came up
and we didn't know where the podcasting
was going to take us we thought the
podcast
thing was going to last maybe a year or
two well it lasted like [__] 20 years
and it took me
to the age of 16 i'm very [__]
grateful for it because
my biggest fear was when i got to the
comedy store
i re i saw a lot of 50 year old guys
when i got to the comedy store i was
probably i don't know
32 33. there was a lot of guys up there
in their 40s couple guys lurking in
their 50s
you walk in the comedy show they have
puppy dog eyes
and they you know they were looking for
a spot or or i don't want to say a
handout but they were looking for
somebody to help them out with something
and that's listen that's great
but when you're 40 and 50
it seems like people don't want to help
you
it seems like you know you're out of
people like but look a little long in
the [__] tooth you know whatever
so people don't want to help you and i
saw a lot of guys up there that it was
kind of sad and again for me i would go
you know what i'm not even going to
worry about that
because number one i'm never gonna be
[__] i'm never gonna do anything with
this comedy [__] i'm just gonna
be one of missy's losers till i'm 50.
hopefully she'll throw me out
and uh i'll just do these [__] d
rooms all around town and
tell people stories when i opened up for
joe rogan on the road and
did i ever tell you about you know and
you're like
you're like really guys so that was my
biggest fear was to be it my biggest
fear of all time was to end up a guy
with a ponytail
with led zeppelin a shirt on at subway
sandwiches
that was my biggest fear or any of those
you you've all seen those guys you're
walking to a gas station
they're [__] 60 they still got a led
zeppelin shirt on and they're working
there and that the kids the 20 year olds
are like impressed with them because
they're like oh we went to see i partied
with jimi hendrix no
you know so right away the young kids
like [__] and that lasts for about
three months until one day you're like
what the [__] you're my dad's age and
you work here my dad's at home watching
[__] the news and you're here working
like a [__] stift it you are four to
twelve and you go to your shitty [__]
apartment trust me there's a lot of guys
that do that and when i was young that's
the life i wanted i want to live like
charles bronson i didn't want to be like
[__] uh
i didn't want to be [__] johnny boom
box with a family and nothing i wanted
my own little room you know maybe a cat
with a bowl of milk next to my bed one
of those little army cards that's what i
thought i was going to end up with so
i never really thought
about that this day would come that i'd
have a daughter or being married you
know
so i worked [__] tremendously hard so
that wouldn't happen i was always
worried about it but when the podcast
came
and also my stand-up started blowing up
a little bit i'm like okay i'm not gonna
be in rough shape when i'm [__] 50
because
i'm gonna forget about
four years ago i got a i was flying to
chicago
and
sitting next to me and when i got to the
airport i saw a comic that's a little
older than i am he was a great comic hbo
specials everything this guy was
[__] great
in the 80s 90s
and then you know he got older you know
and
when i caught him on the plane that day
he was a guy i looked up to for a long
time like i looked up to this guy
but after that plane ride right that day
i was very uh sad with him
you know he was 50 so he was my age now
this had to be maybe five years ago he
was my age now
i was probably 54 you know and uh
he it was just a two-hour plane ride of
negativity
and what and i and i like the guy so i
listened to him i heard him out
but it wasn't negativity uh
it was like negativity but at the same
time it was putting me down
for what i was doing you know for you
know i was rocking the wrong you should
quit now but one of those
nothing's gonna go anywhere these people
suck you know
and i remember that he was mad at me
because i wouldn't tell rogan to put him
on the podcast because he thought
if i get rogan one time on the podcast
his life would change he's the guy
that's been doing comedy for [__] 30
years at the time and he thought that
if he went on rogan's podcast for one
episode everything was gonna [__]
change and i'm like wow
this is kind of scary and i'm like you
know what man i'm gonna make sure
that when i get to that age i don't want
to be bitter about comedy i don't want
this in my life this ain't worth it and
today he's gone he disappeared he
he struck some money by mistake and it
was he just didn't want to do it no more
i i never wanted to be in a position
where i didn't want to do something and
i still had to [__] do it that's
[__] horrible that's horrible that's
a horrible way to live and let me tell
you something 60 of americans look that
way because they bought a house
they invested in a car and now they got
to make car payments they they they
spent over their head you know the last
thing i wanted was that my [__] was
supposed to be my golden years
for me to be breaking my [__] hump
doing i didn't want to doing [__] i
didn't want to [__] do that's what
will kill you you know and it's funny
because
the last two weeks or so the wrestler
has been on have you ever seen the movie
the wrestler
you know i don't i do a movie of the
week on uh
on patreon i do an album of the week a
movie of the week whatever's going on
but the wrestler it was a movie i've
always liked i've always enjoyed the
wrestler first off i'm a big mickey
rourke fan so i understand you know i
liked uh the movie he made with kim
bassinger we put the carrots in a [__]
i like the pope greenwich village i like
[__] um angel heart
i like a lot of [__] his movies a
movie i forget the movie where he played
the eternity and [__]
when the wrestler came out i mean nobody
wanted to do business with uh
him anymore you know nobody
like he had just gotten [__] crazy
but everybody knows all those old dudes
have one great film one great you know
it's like the giants it's like the san
francisco 49ers in the [__] 80s
they would always sign people to one
year contracts guys that were 34 you
know that the team they were with was
unhappy they could see it that young
kids were coming in [__] san
francisco would start him and get that
year and get they would have their best
years they'd be an old men but to have
their best years because they knew they
only had one year
and they wanted to make the best of one
yeah i don't know what mickey rourke was
thinking when he made the wrestler
i liked the wrestling i enjoyed a lot of
parts of the wrestler
but the thing that stuck with me the
most the wrestler is a story
that i dreaded the wrestlers about
mickey rourke and he's an old wrestler
he already fought madison square garden
you know he did all his great things he
fought on pay-per-view sold all these
things but that was in his 30s now he's
like 50 55. he lives in a van
he does steroid they show the whole life
of a wrestler
and i and the funny thing is it's shot
here in new jersey
it's all around you if you as soon as
you see it you'll go holy [__] it's like
uh
the amboys and south uh it's all south
jersey
they uh
this movie is everything i'm i'm and
whenever i see this movie
i'm sad but i'm happy at the same time
that i didn't fall into this i mean
listen let's let's figure this out
if i wouldn't have married my wife terry
if i would have just told terry listen i
don't want to get clean and sober i'm
gonna
i'm gonna keep doing what i'm doing
i love you you go on with your life and
do the best you can i'll keep in touch
with you and stuff because i really love
my wife
but if i didn't like
uh
if i didn't get clean from coke i don't
see my life to be any different than the
wrestler
and that's a horrible [__] story
lonely
you know you live in a [__] van
you live in a trailer
he sleeps in his trailer but when he
doesn't have money for the rent
he has to sleep in the van i know we've
all done that i've done that [__] like a
[__]
you know he has no girlfriend
he had no wife no children he had a
daughter that didn't speak to him remind
you of anybody
so i mean there was just all these
things that you look at
at the end of your life and listen this
guy this character that he played
did great things in wrestling
but you know you get too old to fly to
the [__] end i mean this guy in this
movie you know he's mickey rook's age
this character and he's doing all this
[__] that
young kids got to do he's got to get hit
in the head with chairs and [__] they
cut razor blades and [__] you know
they're spraying bug spray in their eyes
they're [__] throwing them off a lot
you think a 50 year old guy could do
that you got another thing coming
and he's not making thousands of dollars
a fight he's making a couple hundred
here
a couple hundred here he's just putting
a [__] piece i mean there's a part
where he's buying steroids and the guy
goes i gave you 1100 of steroids i know
you only got 400
i'll carry you to the next time you know
that guy knew he wasn't going to get the
back end of the money from the steroids
but it's you have the universe helps you
in a lot of ways i'm watching this movie
and i'm like wow
this would have been me if i wouldn't
have gotten my life together like this
would have been me like after terry
would have left and after the comedy was
gone or maybe the comedy wouldn't be
gone people would still come up to me
and said hey you're the guy from the
longest yard we could use you for this
[__] comedy thing and i gotta go work
a football shirt [__] that i don't want
to [__] do
they show him at like uh
for years my brother works
my brother george is a [__] savage
great framer he frames all this stuff
but he's a framer for comic con in l.a
his company the company he works with
one of the things he does
is he frames every year he begs me
joey you got to come to comic con joey
you got to come to comic-con
i can't go to comic-con
i can't go to comic-con i'll give you
the reasons why
because yeah it's about uh
you know pop culture and all this [__]
that's going on today and they do all
these you know
talks and all this stuff q and a's about
shows and that's all great if you have
the patience and if you like doing that
stuff i like doing that stuff but i
don't want to do it with
10 000 people around me that you know i
want to see pacino talk or something
but the other thing i don't like is the
autograph boots
like the people that sit there
and you come up to me and go hey joey oh
my god i love the longest yard
it's 2050.
that was 2005. you know and here i am
old gray
with a football shirt on giving out
autographs
listen it's a living
it's better than robbing somebody it's
better to sleep on somebody's couch it's
way better than doing anything
i just never wanted to do that i
couldn't see myself [__] sitting
there
and people coming up to me i mean they
show like
like the wrestler like uh mickey rourke
and the wrestler he's at the comic-con
he was too first of all it was not a
comic-con it was a vfw
and then
and they didn't even put them in the
back like on sundays in old bridge they
have a vfw uh an old bridge i think it
is
and they do a baseball card show
and i went there one day and i was like
oh this is [__] crazy i like that i
bought some cards for mercy and a friend
bought some cards but it was kind of
you know it's it's the micro
you know it's not like a big place with
lights and pictures of [__] bruce lee
it's just a vfw that smells like piss
and people go in there and buy [__]
cards on sundays no big deal but
he had a comic-con at a vfw somewhere in
jersey maybe camden or something like
that that's what it looked like like
camden or one of those [__] places
and the guys were falling asleep
like the other wrestlers and he was
looking at the other wrestlers one
wrestler was in a wheelchair
one wrestler had like a fake leg
a little bit like two wrestlers just to
sleep you know there was one wrestler
that was drunk
and it just shows the sadness
it shows
the sadness of that life
you know like
it's all great and dandy when the lights
are on and stuff but once the light
turns on
and the show is over
you're in a [__] you're sleeping with
mice
you know at the end of your [__] life
which
it just didn't work for me man i just
didn't want to
be that guy and over the years
as a comic you know as a young comic you
have to work b rooms
and sea rooms you're like joey what the
[__] is an a room what's this an a room
is an improv an a room is a theater
an a room is uh the denver comedy works
is an a room they got a lot of [__]
stars there
uh
the comedy store is obviously a [__]
a room
the improv comedy clubs are a rooms
caroline's is an a room
gotham is an a room
then there's the little clubs the
smaller mom and pop shops
they're either a b room or a c room
depending on what they fall into it like
uncle vinnie's where i perform it's a
great club
but it's in between a c and a b room
okay you're not going to get too many
you're not you're not going to get the
rogans and the sebastian's and not
because it's not a good club it's a
small club it only seats 150
people sebastian's going to do a show
they have to stay there for two months
and do a show every day to reach
everybody so that's the only reason why
like that's the differences
so
you know you always opt you want to play
in the a room but when you get older you
don't draw anymore
you don't uh you know you can't do the
longer weeks so there's
comedy rooms for the fridays and
saturdays poughkeepsie
you know little rooms like yeah you have
the
zany's in nashville
but i think jackson has a smaller comedy
club and then there's another place a
beer garden that does comedy you know if
you can't get into the zany zimbra uh
into
zany's you know so
but towards the end of your career those
are the rooms you'll be playing
zayn easy after guy like listen
and there's another thing
when i got into comedy
not when i got into when i got into
touring in 2009 like by myself not with
joe and not with anybody else or andrew
or anybody else
they told me to always be a gentleman at
these clubs
they were like always
be a gentleman at these improvs because
every time you go to an improv as a
comic
your guarantee gets raised
joey what's a guarantee okay
when you first go to a club or something
it's your first time in the club
headlining they're probably going to
give you fifteen hundred dollars plus a
pay plane ticket you're gonna do a
thousand [__] shows
1500 plus a plane ticket sometimes they
don't even give you a [__] plane
ticket
so if you're getting 1500 bucks and if
the [__] plane thickets 400
you get 900 now
so always think about all these things
i'm talking about here and i'll let you
know if it's with a plane ticket it was
not with a plane ticket
once you get a little older they don't
you know it's like when the wrestler
walked in to do a gig everybody was
changing in like a dressing room like a
like a locker room that smelled like
dick
and what did they do they put him in the
boiler room that smelled like more dick
like that's the vip section of the club
you know the boiler room
at that point you accepted when you were
younger you go what the [__] is this i'm
not performing here i mean this comics
was a comic when i started
that if you sent a black limo for him he
wouldn't get in the [__] car he would
get back on the plane and go back home
guys a black a white [__] limo if he
didn't have a white limo
and you if you send a black limo
he would go home
so when that guy's in the 60s
he's gonna have a hard time finding
[__] work because
they have green rooms with like you're
not you're in the [__] manager's
office
you know like a lot of people always go
to me i want to go underground i
remember when i went to buffalo as a guy
that tortured me all weekend i want to
go in the green room i want to go in the
green room i finally brought him in the
green room and said i go there's the
green room
and he goes where's the party what
this is the green room
what is your perception that happens in
the green you think i got a chick back
there that's cutting toenails and
sucking [__] and
food and people flying to it there's
nothing going on it's me felicia and
whoever i'm seeing and we're talking
about a movie we saw two weeks ago
nobody's drinking nobody's [__]
jumping up and down nobody's od
so
you know people some people just don't
get it but when you go to a club the
first time as a comic you always want to
make a good impression like i bombed in
in columbus
but i was a gentleman
okay what's a gentleman you don't drink
you don't hit on the wait staff
you don't hit on anybody in the [__]
club you just go there do your thing and
be as nice as you can
every time you go to those clubs if you
do a good job you get a raise
you keep getting a raise every year i
don't know it goes up 500 maybe a
thousand if you really you know and it
goes and then one day you just blow out
of that and you go into a theater and it
but if you're a gentleman all those
years to that improv
or that funny bum
whatever your guarantee is it stays
there
so even though i might not be selling
tickets in three [__] years
i'll still have that guarantee i
guarantee i work my way up to get that
guarantee
do you follow me
once you go to a b room and see room
when you get older the guarantee
disappears
so
either you stay it like for me i would
stay in improvs
i could stay at the empires if i
traveled and [__] i would stay at the
improv until i'm [__]
six until the improvs put me in there
because i have a nice relationship with
them
so but that's the thing if you're a
[__] they won't bring you back
so when you're old the reward that you
get is you don't have to sell that many
tickets
but we'll bring you back twice as a
thank you
i said thank you for being a gentleman
all those years and for always coming
here on time and for selling tickets and
from promoting your dates that that goes
a long [__] way you know so
yeah if you ever
want to know what life is for people
after the [__] fun is over
and you don't get treated it's like
watching rocky you know rocky got
treated like [__] before that happened
you know they took his locker away they
[__] you know rocky just got thrown
to the wolves
and then he won then he got everything
to [__] back but if rocky would have
stayed in the thing then your manager
goes away because remember if you're not
making money you think these managers
are going to stick around no
so all these older guys got no we got no
protection
we just count on mike can i come april
23rd yeah i don't know what's gonna
happen when i'm there
because i don't sell tickets now i gotta
do [__] i don't wanna do you might send
me to a mall to give out flyers at a
mall that's not what i wanna do at 60
[__] years old
but if i want to [__] work this is
what i'm gonna have to do
so do you understand how it works when
you want to see
that wrestler movie had nothing
and it's what i tell people an art is an
art is an art
you know
jimmy page walks into [__] the spec
uh the garden right now whatever band's
on stage will give him the guitar
nice and easy
jimmy page could walk into the [__]
garden tomorrow how are you doing i'm
here to see rage against the machine and
they'll look at them do you have tickets
do i look like i need [__] tickets
do i i'm jimmy [__] paige i'm walking
right to the green room and i want to
talk to [__] tom morello and
figure out what extra guitars he has
that's how he's walking in there because
he's an old man he doesn't know
then when he gets down there like either
they're gonna go
holy [__]
it's jimmy [__] paige but if jimmy
like i love ace freely right from kiss
like ace freely is a [__] savage but
they freely is a man without a [__]
flag like he's just doing [__] himself
he's a kiss so a lot of people are like
oh we don't have to do anything face
freely because he's not a member of the
kiss army
do you see how it works guys it's kind
of [__] weird how goofy these people
get but gene simmons still gets [__]
great treatment
but these guys could walk into anywhere
and go i'm here to perform with a band
they're on legend status
they're on legend status and yeah you'll
come in and sing something
some stupid song like get back i don't
want to get back by the beatles i was
watching that thing last week from uh
the foo fighters and it was very
interesting until paul mccartney came on
with the chick from the pretenders
oh
i don't know what he was [__] singing
but it didn't sound good like this is
the first this is the first time he's
ever performed that time that song live
yeah he should have performed it live 50
years ago people gave a [__]
not now 40 years
yeah come on man
but he's a legend
so i mean
he's a legend status but he and he
walked right the [__] on there but
did you see ringo starr there
nobody gives a [__] about ringo
and ringo's still touring still trying
to do his submarine band
still you know he sold banal and the
whole thing
but it's a it's a shitty [__] world
for an old actor
it's a shitty [__] world for an old
wrestler it's a shitty [__] world for
an old comic
and i am
grateful
every [__] day when i wake up
then i don't have to go through that
[__] like
beg to put me on stage or anything i
give that
this makes me the happiest that i could
be
you know i always looked at dominic
chianissi's career you know
dominic chianissi was in godfather two
he was in in gotti he was in a couple
movies and then when he's 60 [__]
three or 64 he gets the break of a
[__] lifetime he gets the break of a
[__] lifetime
and
you're old you know you're [__] old
you can't do the same [__] you used to
but you
you still do the best you [__] can i
mean i love dominic chiannis he became a
star when he was 70 [__] years old
those are the guys you know that you
[__] look at and go they survived
this and they did it the right way
and now they don't have to do stupid
[__] i never really had to work with old
actors the only guy i worked with that
wasn't on top of his you know he wasn't
the guy he was when he shot goodfellas
was like paul i forget what his name is
paul vario whoever played paul vario i
did a movie with him the raging bull
and he was older and he was great
he sang italian songs all night with a
guitar you know he [__] told them
slow down i'm old i work on my own pace
like you know yeah they you know they
they catered to him a little bit he knew
his lines you know i worked with rodney
when he was old and that [__]
did not know his [__] lines
and they had to read them off the camera
so he would go live
mike would say go [__] yourself lie
tell him go [__] go [__] yes i mean that
was how bad his memory was but my point
is listen man
i enjoyed the wrestler because it lets
you know what happens if you don't get
your [__] life together then he has a
[__] heart attack
then he finally meets a girl
and then they tell him he can't wrestle
anymore because he'll die and he [__]
takes the last wrestling match and
it's [__] great it all works out for
him but
just to see
what his life is about
now compared to what it was then you
know
like i'm trying to think of a band right
now that well
a lot of the bands that are on tour
right now take quiet ride okay let's
talk about rudy sargent quiet right
obviously they're not the same quiet
riot from [__] 40 years ago
you know but
they're making it happen i just got an
email they're playing uh
in bergen county
april 2nd or something like that i can't
wait to see rudy because last time they
played they played in violin i'm scared
to go to vineland they'll kill you down
there
so i don't know what the [__] happened
in violin
but no i really enjoyed the [__]
wrestler the last couple weeks and
that's the reason i think i enjoyed it
as much as i did because
when i first saw the wrestler i thought
i was gonna end up like that
and there's nothing wrong with ending up
like that i mean you know
it happens to the [__] best but
before anything
now for a word for my [__]
sponsors
i'm sorry to take that break from the
podcast but listen i gotta talk to you
about better help
sometimes you can fix that other problem
so long that you can't take the time to
find the solution it can be tough to
train your brain to stay in
problem-solving mode when facing with
challenges of life but when you you
learn how to find your solutions there's
no better feeling and a therapist can
help you become a better problem solver
making it easier for you to accomplish
your goals listen
when i was stuck
i had to turn to therapy and guess what
it helped because two heads are better
than one and that's what happens when
you get together with better help better
help is an online therapy that offers
video phone and chat therapy sessions
you can choose not to see anybody if you
don't want to but it's a lot more
affordable than in-person therapy and i
can get you a therapist within 48 hours
right now if you try to get a
face-to-face therapist you're going to
wait a year
let's get this party started now to be a
better you with better help when you
want to be a better problem solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com
diaz
d-i-a-z and i'm gonna get you 10
off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
diaz they'll help you with whatever
problem you may have and now back to the
show
all right you bad [__] sorry
about that i almost forgot about better
help you gotta take care
of your [__] coconut [__] last
week
school started
she's doing great in [__] school it's
great to see all the kids listen man
i love this time of the year
yesterday i mean i went out for a cup of
coffee i went out to my backyard to
drink a cup of coffee and [__]
leaves were everywhere leaves already
i mean it's a beautiful fall [__] uh
i'm just excited about this whole thing
and i'm excited about saturday night
you know
i haven't been in a big venue in a long
time i did those shows with bert and i
didn't really know what i was doing
i did those two shows with joe and i was
[__] completely lost in atlantic city
and i did a show with tom segura and
i'll never forget that was the first
time i was on stage in a while when i
got off stage with tom segura i actually
had a [__] sit down for 30 or 40
minutes because
i thought my head was gonna [__] blow
up it was just overwhelming so
i was very happy that i got to do those
eight or nine shows and uncle vinnie's i
did a couple spots at distress factory i
did a couple spots at
uh asbury park and i got to be honest
with you guys i had a great time on
stage was what i really wanted to do i
wanted to have fun again you know
none of this [__]
is ever any good unless you have fun and
the last
three or four years i was going on the
road yeah i was bringing people i
enjoyed like dean and kate and
just steve simone
and lee excuse me
but
i wasn't traveling in a big group like
when i used to go on the road with joe
and hari and duncan
it was [__] fun it was fun you know
we would me and duncan would go up to
the roof at the hotel and smoke pot just
little stupid [__] that we did
and for some reason the last five or six
years seven years
with the theaters and the numbers and
[__] it just really wasn't fun anymore
it wasn't
it was work
and
one of the greats eddie murph eddie
murphy
eddie griffin once told me that [__]
he got into comedy so he didn't have to
work
and for years whenever i would see eddie
i would go how you doing he's like man
i'm not having a good time
these [__] are making me work
and uh
it's fun you know like when you make
money it's great to go out
but if you're not having a [__]
tremendous time
it it's it's and this is what i had to
remind myself of
these last four months weren't about me
writing material or me trying to [__]
write a one-hour special i'm not even
looking for that anymore
i was looking just to go have comedy
just go do comedy and laugh my ass off
on stage while i'm doing it and not
worry about netflix and not worry about
what's coming out of your [__] mouth
because somebody's going to get offended
and not worried about just stupid [__]
that has nothing
to do with stand-up when you look at
judy carter's stand-up comedy book
it doesn't mention anything what i was
going through doing stand-up the last
five years
but it never also mentioned that
stand-up you should be [__] having a
blast
you know i stopped smoking dope before i
went on stage there was you know when i
wa from 2012 to 2013 i was eating
[__] 18 000 milligrams and going on
stage and forgetting my [__] material
and
laughing and giggling and just doing all
this [__] that was basic
but then when the numbers and the
theaters and the agents and people
started calling you it just took it a
lot it took
it's not what i signed up for
you know
it's like when you go into the nfl you
know these kids that play football when
they're five and then when they're in
high school they play high school
[__] football then they go to college
and all they want to do is play football
and then you get to the nfl and they got
9 000 [__] rules and yes you're
getting paid millions of dollars a year
and you enjoy playing football so you'll
[__] follow the rules like you know
uh when i did the longest shot you know
there were a couple nfl players on there
and they would tell me little things
what they had to do
didn't sound like [__] fun like brian
bosworth got fined because he wouldn't
tuck his shirt in every week
that's my [__] prerogative if i want
to touch my shirt you don't even know
what's going on maybe i tuck my shirt
and my balls are too big and the shirt
gets cancelled in my underwear you have
no [__] idea but if you're gonna find
me
for you know like all that [__] that's
the [__] i cannot deal with at all
and with comedy it started popping up
more you guys see it
people criticizing your material people
taping your [__] sets and taking them
it's not supposed to be that
it was just supposed to be fun
i'm supposed to go to your town i'm like
[__] grand funk railroad you know i'm
supposed to come to your town and party
out with you [__]
but it doesn't become that it's not even
close to that
it's work and people don't go out there
there's too many people you can't you
know so i was like i'm done with this
[__] and now i'm starting to have
[__] fun again just
basic fun i don't want to [__] take
listen the comedy thing says
a comedy show it said nothing about a
small photography [__] session
you know i'm saying like nobody said
that so for years i was like if i got to
go over there i got to take a bunch of
pictures no more i'm not doing it
it wasn't fun for me anymore
fun for me was going on stage cracking
jokes and then finishing the show and
going in the back and hanging out with
my friends and the other comics and
goofing it wasn't going out there and i
didn't like it no more last weekend i
tried it last weekend uncle vinnie's no
pictures i go right to the back that's
it it's over i just want to
do comedy and everything else was worm
me
the [__] down it's over this is all
about having fun
and i'm gonna remind you again this is
all about having fun
and i forgot that
i turned it into a [__] business and
you have to at some point you have to
but you always got to have a little bit
of fun
nothing
is worth it if you're not going to have
fun
think about it even your job you go to
your job not because you like your job
you go to your job because you enjoy the
people you work with
you enjoy the people you work with maybe
there's a nice chinese restaurant up the
corner there's all these little things
you wouldn't go to your [__] job if
you weren't having a good time
that makes that job suck dick
that's why some kid hit me up this
weekend on patreon i don't know my boss
quit
listen i got two favorite [__] lines
if you're walking on ice you might as
well dance and [__] uh what's the
other one i always say
i was looking for a job when i found
this [__]
[Music]
so
before i'm gonna work here and get
ulcers and get [__] uh you know
what's that [__] when you what brock
lesnar had colitis and all that before
you get all this [__]
remember one thing
if you're not having fun it's not gonna
[__] work
i got stew finer coming saturday night
lee syat's doing a little jewish spot up
front
arie sheffield be there
so
i did that on purpose because i want to
have [__] fun
giggle jump up and down
uh laughing gas will be there giving out
some [__] samples for you guys
i spoke to the sony hall people last
week they are [__] tremendous
they are as just as excited as i am so
this is what this week is about putting
a couple jokes together you know all
those years with those specials you have
to worry about what you say i don't want
to do that no more i don't even know
what i want to do i don't even know when
i go up there that's the thing about me
i don't like doing the same set twice
so i don't know what i want to do now i
got to work on this [__] one set and
repeat it vibrate them for the [__]
special that shit's done i'm done with
all that [__]
my goal from now till they put me in the
[__] grave
is to have fun that's it like sheryl
crow all i want to do is have some fun
i'm sick and tired of going up there all
tense you you can't do the material
about the baby who gives a [__]
have a great time [__] it's
monday
it was the 20th anniversary yesterday 21
years we're liberating i'm here to
remind you we're americans [__]
do your thing live your life and
remember we're number one we don't
[__] bow down for nobody i'm a felon
and i won't bow down for nobody as an
american that's what it means to be a
[__] american stay black i love you
[__] have a great monday and i'll
see you
son of a [__] wednesday the 14th
tip top magoo and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much for listening today
it was a great little chit chat with you
guys i'm sorry about the 11 but anyway
the the joint is brought to you by
better help listen
sometimes you fixate on a problem for so
long that you don't know how to find the
solution it could be tough to train your
brain to stay in problem solving mode
when you're faced with a challenge in
life but when you learn how to find your
own solutions there's no better feeling
a therapist can help you accomplish your
better problem solver make it easier to
accomplish your goals listen
therapy
is help right now a lot of people are
confused they don't know what's going on
if you're having a hard time focusing
whatever i suggest you contact better
help they're an online therapy that
offers video phone
and chat therapy sessions you can choose
not to see anyone on camera if you like
and it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and guess what else it
works so do me a favor
go to betterhelp.com right now preston
code diaz d-i-a-z and i'm going to get
you 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
diaz when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can help you out
so go to betterhelp.com
diaz to get 10 off your first month
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings listen
opening week you missed it you're [__]
up it was action-packed and we made a
little [__] scotl get ready for week
two tonight with denver against seattle
the action starts
this evening with draftking sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the nfl this week new customers can bet
just five dollars on any football game
and get 203 bets
instantly now you want more action
that's tremendous i got more action for
you
everyone can experience the thrill of
draftkings early win promotion it's
simple better than any nfl team to win
if your team leads by ten and eight
point of the game you get paid instantly
even if the team comes back to beat them
who's better than you draftkings that's
who download the draftking sportsbook
app today use promo code joey j-o-e-y to
get 203 bets instantly when you place a
final bet on a football game that's code
joey only at draftkings sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details and now
if nothing else is bothering you
download the draftking sportsbook app
and go win some [__] money i
want to thank draftkings and i want to
thank better help but i want to thank
you guys for always supporting and
watching
the show we'll be back wednesday morning
tip top magoo have a great day and a
great week
[Music]
you